violence sous prétexte donc une
manifestation et d'expression de droit
démocratique
on incite à la haine on estime m est-ce
que sincèrement vous êtes certains que
le scrutin du 31 octobre sera maintenu à
la date prévue
il n'y a pas de raison que ce scrutin ne
soit pas maintenu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la crise du corona virus s'aggrave en
amérique latine la situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
présidant un brésilien g1 max hoarau ni
la gravité lada pandémie il a été élu
c'est par un dictateur il reste encore
populaire et donc évidemment sa façon de
se comporter par rapport au virus a de
l'impact auprès des brésiliens
aujourd'hui le gouvernement travaille
fortement pour s'approprier les
territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaît nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
on s'en va tous nous sommes ensemble
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
voici les grands titres de l'actualité
de ce mercredi 9 septembre à le
gouvernement français va devoir prendre
des décisions difficiles c'était l'ère
cet après-midi de président du conseil
scientifique en réponse à la
recrudescence du coronavirus en
attendant de nombreuses voix s'élèvent
pour remettre en cause la stratégie des
tests de dépistage de qu'ovide 19 la
crise sanitaire parmi les sujets phares
du séminaire de rentrée du gouvernement
aujourd'hui autre thème abordé les
questions de sécurité et le séparatisme
le gouvernement défend son bilan évoque
les recrutements policiers et la hausse
de budget pour le ministère de la
justice notre éditorial sera consacrée à
ce thème
au chapitre social general electric
taillé dans ses effectifs français la
branche énergie du géant américain
prévoit de supprimer 1225 emplois en
europe dont 764 rien qu'en france
l'annnonce de ce plan social doit être
officialisée la semaine prochaine lors
d'un comité européen
les pays du sud de l'union européenne
réunis demain en corse autour d'
emmanuel macron au coeur des discussions
les tensions en méditerranée orientale
objectif selon l'élysée faire progresser
le consensus sur la relation de l'union
européenne avec la turquie en vue
notamment du sommet européen des 24 et
25 septembre à bruxelles
[Musique]
la situation sanitaire en france et les
derniers chiffres plutôt inquiétants
fourni ce soir par la direction de la
santé 8577 nouveau cadre de covile
confirmé par un test
le pays compte 386 nouvelles
hospitalisations liées au virus en 24
heures
71 patients sont entrés en réanimation
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils ont fait un total
de 599 il ait eue dans le même temps 20
morts liées au virus
l hôpital et pour contrer la progression
importante un de ces contaminations vous
le savez des tests de dépistage rapide
dit test antigénique commencent à être
déployés
mais les scientifiques s'interrogent
dépistage non ciblés embouteillages dans
les labos délais plus longs parfois pour
les résultats la stratégie mise en place
en france est elle vraiment efficace
selon des spécialistes elle serait même
contre productive écouter notamment
l'avis de bruno merga man chef de
service à l'hôpital lariboisière à paris
oui il est possible effectivement en
raison de la limitation d'accès aux
tests et du délai pour obtenir le
résultat est qu'effectivement le
dépistage plus massif soit pas optimale
effectivement si on obtient son résultat
plusieurs jours après le contact
potentiellement de contaminants et
qu'entre temps on ne sait pas isolé et
bien on continue à diffuser le virus
dans la communauté et donc effectivement
très probablement il faut opter
désormais pour des tests plus rapide est
également probablement hiérarchiser les
indications pour permettre le dépistage
rapide des personnes symptomatique et
contacts al'inverse des sujets qui
demande un dépistage plus pour confort
ou pour se rassurer et autre point
épineux les tests pcr qui laisse les
chercheurs perplexe puisque il ne
saurait pas à 100% fiable
le gouvernement veut aller vite mais ce
la bonne solution
éléments de réponse avec mona
mou dès lors face aux coronavirus pas
simple de s'y retrouver entre les
différents dépistages à leur efficacité
et c'est bien là le problème est les
tests pcr ne serait pas si fiable selon
les experts plusieurs personnes ont été
diagnostiquées positive alors qu'elle
portait une infime quantité du virus et
ne serait donc pas contagieuse en
revanche il existe 20 à 30% de tests
faussement est négative alors avec
toutes ses contradictions comment s'y
retrouver
selon les chiffres du gouvernement un
million de tests sont actuellement
réalisés chaque semaine en france contre
700 milles hebdomadaire au cours du mois
d'août
cela ne permet pourtant pas de freiner
la circulation de l'épidémie avec un
taux de positivité qui continue
d'augmenter
dépassant désormais les 5 % vous avez le
choix entre deux tests le naso pharyngé
dit pcr qui permet de dire si vous avez
le colis 19
le test sanguin permet lui de savoir si
vous avez déjà été en contact avec le
coronavirus et si vous avez développé
des anticorps pour remédier à la
saturation de plus en plus importante
des laboratoires olivier ferrand le
ministre de la santé a annoncé la mise
en place de tests rapides antigénique
qui se fera également par voie nasale
le prélèvement est ensuite mélangé un
réactif déposé sur une bandelette et qui
se colorent si le résultat est positif
le délai de réponse est rapide il
suffira de 15 à 30 minutes
un test qui pourrait être utilisée
également dans les hôpitaux et aéroports
le délai court pourrait permettre de
casser les chaînes de transmission mais
le test antigénique est réputé moins
sensible que les tests pcr olivier
verront le ministre de la santé mise
beaucoup sur ce nouveau mal de dépistage
le test antigénique pourrait être
bientôt disponible cette semaine le
gouvernement veut faire vite en
proposant de nouvelles alternatives mais
si elle est est traditionnel noeud
on passe yable à 100% rien ne permet de
confirmer que celui ci le sera en autres
types de tests 10 à l'hiver pourrait
aussi voir le jour mais les essais
cliniques sont toujours en cours et
c'est dans ce contexte qu'est sera
zeneca suspend les essais de son vaccin
contre le coronavirus une décision du
groupe pharmaceutique anglo-suédois
après l'apparition d'une maladie
inexpliqués chez l'un des volontaires
britannique astrazeneca après vendu des
centaines de millions de doses à de
multiples pays plus qu'aucun de ses
concurrents et puis en russie
les premiers moscovites ont recommencé à
se faire vacciner aujourd'hui près de
35000 personnes se sont portées
volontaires vaccination dont contre le
quoran à mieux se lancer dans le cadre
des essais post enregistrement du vexin
aarhus spoutnik v premier élaboré dans
le monde les volontaires recevront deux
vaccins en l'espace de 21 jours le
ministre russe de la santé annonce que
les premiers lots seront prochainement
envoyés dans d'autres régions russes et
en france on lisait en tout cas
difficile de faire un test sans faire la
queue pendant des heures
pas facile non plus de savoir lequel
pratiques et virologiques ou sérologique
sans compter la course au vaccin dont on
vient de parler engagées par de nombreux
laboratoires on s'y retrouve plus d'où
le thème de notre débat ce soir test
vaccin est ce le grand flou pour en
parler nous sommes en direct avec un
philippe frau gel froguel pardon
chercheur professeur à l'impérial
collège de londres et à l'université
lille 2 bonsoir philippe froguel merci
d'être avec nous elle vaut côté jérôme
martin médecin généraliste président de
l'union française pour une médecine
libre bonsoir docteur marc cimer
smarties merci également d'être avec
nous alors ce sont des files d'attentes
interminables à en france pour se faire
dépister on l'a vu sur toutes les
chaînes de télé où on l'a même
d'ailleurs parfois vécu un n'est ce pas
nous mêmes des
or après d'attentes pour attendre le
résultat alors que ça va plus vite il
faut bien le dire chez nos voisins
européens comme en allemagne ou en grèce
comment vous vous expliquer cette
différence on commence par jérôme marty
la différence elle est due au fait que
on voit bien toute la population une
grande partie de la population de se
faire tester on fait du chalutage dans
la population quelque sorte on n'a pas
défini de groupes à risques et tout le
monde y va tout le monde peut y aller en
plus sans ordonnance du médecin
donc ça ça a créé un engouement très
important avec une peur de la population
d'être contaminés donc des gens qui
parfois se font tester plusieurs fois et
des des laboratoires qui sont emboliser
on leur en plus cela fléché tout le
monde voyait laboratoire plutôt que
choisir de multiplier les sites on
aurait pu demander aux médecins aux
infirmières aux pharmaciens aux
biologistes de de tester ça n'a pas été
le cas
et puis et puis la grande erreur c'est
que on n'a pas voulu définir les lieux à
risque et les groupes à risques et
privilégier les tests dans ces couples
alors maintenant on en est là voilà des
tests qui sont beaucoup trop lents
beaucoup trop structurellement parce que
il faut il ya il y à cette attente
et puis quand on va voir son médecin on
a déjà pu commencer avec théorisé deux
jours avant les symptômes on va voir son
médecin
deux jours après les symptômes il vous
dit d'aller vous faire tester il faut
trois jours et pour avant le diagnostic
il faut encore deux jours ce qui veut
dire qu'on obtient un diagnostic dix
jours après d'avoir commencé avec thau
risée du virus ce qui est beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup trop sanguin gérant
par marty parle de de lenteur on évoque
de plus en plus ces tests antigénique
dont on vient de parler vous y croyez
vous à 7 à cette solution s'est pas
encore la bonne stratégie
les testons antigénique sont beaucoup
moins sensibles par définition parce que
l'adn on est on est capable de ce qu'on
appelle de l'enfant l'amplifier c'est à
dire que même si on n'a que quelques
virus
on peut l'augmenter a artificiellement
ce qui nous permet de le détecter alors
que pour l'antigène on sait pas faire
et donc s'il ya que très peu de
particules virales dans le nez bien on
les trouvera pas donc c'est connu c'est
rien de nouveau on sait que la
sensibilité est très faible
beaucoup plus faible en tout cas que la
pcr mais moi je dois dire une chose
c'est que effectivement on aurait plus a
décidé autrement que d'ouvrir à tout le
monde
les tests pcr mais c'est pas ce qu'a
décidé le gouvernement et donc banos on
peut pas revenir en arrière à mon avis
mais la vraie question c'est pourquoi
les laboratoires privés qui font 90 %
des thèses sont aujourd'hui incapables
de faire en 48 heures et s'était engagé
à ça et ça c'est totalement anormal
est ce que des gens comme moi on
proposait depuis très longtemps depuis
le mois de mars avril c'est-à-dire des
gens comme moi ces gars de là les gens
de la recherche génomique
nous faisons des dizaines de milliers de
pcr par jour et donc on sait ce que ça
veut dire
on a proposé de s'associer soi et des
chu soit des grands groupes de
laboratoire biologique par exemple
servent alliance par ap exemple bio
groupe pareil par exemple synlab et de
monter des plateformes régionales qui
fonctionnerait quand on en a besoin
c'est à dire que si on la ville de
marseille est en l'état d'épidémie
avancé eh bien il faut à marseille
capable de faire quarante mille
personnes 50 une personne voire cent
mille personnes en quelques jours et ça
aujourd'hui personne n'est capable de le
faire parce que le choix du gouvernement
c'est certes un million mais 1 millions
/ 5000 laboratoire or il aurait fallu
faire des grandes plateformes d'e comme
c'est fait par exemple en angleterre
comme c'est faire en allemagne il à ce
moment là on pourra réconcilier savez ce
que mon collègue vient de dire c'est à
dire de le faire dans des endroits où au
moment où on a besoin c'est pas
aujourd'hui encore est ce qu'on a besoin
de faire passer à thé à marseille c'est
en seine saint denis par exemple ou à
paris et vous même il est là et bien
c'est là où c'est plate forme serait
utile et ça le gouvernement a refusé de
le faire j'ai jamais compris pourquoi ça
ça fait cinq mois qu'on demande ça n'est
pas trop tard mais si on ne le fait pas
non pas comment on va s'en sortir les
masques on a bien vu que les masques
c'est pas la panacée c'est un
retardateur
pas plus c'est comme vous avez un feu de
forêt des canadairs qui leur balance un
retardateur et bien il faut le quéré
pompiers et bien les masques ça va faire
que les gens sont moins affectés au
travail dans le métro et tout ça marche
très bien mais c'est pas une panacée
donc si on n'a pas les tests rapides on
peut pas isoler les gens on va écouter
martin blachier puis les mots nazis
juste avant de redonner la parole à
jérôme marty un médecin de santé
publique il était sur notre antenne et
vous allez l'entendre il est justement
très dubitatif sur l'efficacité des
tests que l'on pratique sans doute
beaucoup de 14 haine et de quarantaine
qui sont inutiles dans la mesure où on
sait que la plupart des gens qui vont se
faire tester sont des gens qui pensent
avoir été en contact avec le dews qui
donc se mettre en isolement et on sait
que confier les tests on a 5 % de
positif donc très probablement un grand
nombre de gens qui s'isolent alors que
le contact qu'ils ont eue avec une
personne que lui de plus ce n'est pas
vraiment un risque je pense qu'il
faudrait trier effectivement à la fois
les tests mais aussi les quarantaines un
philippe froguel
il faisait allusion tout à l'heure le
trir il ya trop de monde jérôme marty
c'est votre analyse
également on n'est pas efficace dans la
façon d'aborder le problème nous sommes
tous des scientifiques la base de notre
isolement c'est la logique ça va faire
maintenant des semaines que on teste des
centaines de milliers de personnes
on a en gros entre 3000 et 9000 cas
positifs par jour et qu'on a des équipes
de l'assurance maladie qui font des
enquêtes qu'on appelle le contact racing
où sont les statistiques on a besoin de
ces statistiques on a on a enquêté
auprès de centaines de centaines de
milliers de personnes
moi j'ai besoin de savoir qui se
contaminent quand on se contaminent où
se contaminent dans quelles conditions
se contaminent et à partir de là avec
des statistiques fines on sera
précisément quels sont les groupes à
risque ou est-ce qu'il faut taper ou
est-ce qu'il faut tester et là on sera
beaucoup plus efficace si on fait du
chalutage pour une population elle si on
laisse n'importe qui se testait on en
arrivera par n'importe quel moyen que
l'on fera on aura toujours des files
d'attenté comme le dit martin blachier
on aura en plus des tests qui
globalement par moment ne servent à rien
à cause des faux positifs et ses jeux
véritablement possible l'avons testé
qu'on soit efficace on est dans une
course contre la montre
on voit bien qu'on a les chiffres qui
montrent on va très probablement vers
une augmentation des hospitalisations et
des animations qui va continuer si on
veut casser cette épidémie on a besoin à
la fois des moyens de prévention et on a
besoin de tester efficacement donc c'est
non seulement des tests efficaces mais
quand je dis tester efficacement
c'est vraiment aller vers les groupes à
risque comme le fait de rester dans
l'album philippe froguel à un autre
problème que rencontre effectivement les
potentiels contaminées depuis des
semaines on a vu ces tests contre le
coronavirus se multiplier comme des
petits pains il ya les tests
sérologiques dont on parle souvent les
tests virologiques les écouvillon les
tests sanguins on est un petit peu
perdues en tant que patient sur celui
qu'on doit faire réellement comment s'en
sortir justement est-ce qu'il ya cette
pédagogie selon vous pour l'instant on
n'a pas beaucoup de choix puisque les
seuls qui sont autorisés au me guide
c'est les tests pcr à partir du nez ou
alors les tests sérologiques qui ne
servent à rien pour diagnostiquer
quelqu'un qui n'ajuste est d'être
contaminés donc pour l'instant on en est
là alors le gouvernement dit qu'il y
aura des tests antigénique bientôt bon
genre pourra les utiliser
ça sera ça sera déjà quelque chose
malgré leurs limites
et puis à les fameux tests salivaires à
nous on avait proposé au gouvernement
quand je dis nous c'est à dire les
chercheurs 1 du cinéma c'est nissan
avait proposé au gouvernement au mois
d'avril a travaillé sur les tests
salivaires
on nous a en gros répondu qu' on
n'intéresse personne et que ce n'était
pas utile que les tests sérologiques lé
remplacer tout parce que ça c'est une
chose que je peux vous garantir c'est
que au mois de mars avril à comité de
conseil scientifique monsieur delfraissy
les autres pensaient qu'il y aurait que
les tests sérologiques dauphine dont
fait une erreur méthodologique et
l'homme c'est aussi pour ça qu'on n'a
pas développé les alternatives
antigénique pcr salivaires et autres
parce que il ya eu cette illusion que
les tests sérologiques allait remplacer
tout parce qu'on vivait en temps sur
l'histoire de l'arrivée
et autres donc y'a rien d'extraordinaire
aujourd'hui les tests salivaires
c'est très bien mais bon ça demande un
prélèvement salivaire il y aura là que
pour pour cracher au lieu d'avoir la
queue pour le nez mais c'est va pas
changer fondamentalement les chevaux
sauf que ça fait moins mal et que
peut-être ils font du personnel qui soit
un peu moins bien formés mais je dépeins
forêt mais aussi des problèmes
d'homologation easy cover on a eu un bon
l'été une société montpelliéraine qui
travaille avec des chercheurs comme vous
du cnrs à montpellier qui travaillent
sur ces tests mais on a du mal à les
homologué pourquoi c'est aussi long
jérôme marty je peux pas répondre à
cette question je sais pas c'est cette
structure est la nôtre notre régime
administratif c'est tout à fait possible
c'est qu'on a une lourdeur
administrative au fond des de beaucoup
de protocoles beaucoup de procédures que
à chaque fois comme le disait coluche
vous faire venir l'indien il fallait des
nuages de fumée etc
c'est très franco-français ce système là
quoi ces voix là c'est la seule
explication que je peux avoir la
lourdeur administrative pour revenir sur
les tests salivaires le grand avantage
aussi qu'il y aurait avait des tests
rapides et non traumatique c'est le test
groupe et le test à l'entreprise etc où
on peut faire ce qu'on appelle le
pooling c'est à dire on peut tester
mettons 60 personnes on va mettre tout
ça dans le même réactif si leur actif et
positif on va a fait tester
individuellement
s'il est négatif on écarte cette
personne et on veut donc on voit donc
qu'on peut faire du test répétitif
groupés et là je pense en particulier
aux sportifs aux sportifs de haut niveau
mais c'est aussi deux de moins haut
niveau on pourrait très bien comme ça
regardez si une équipe est est positive
ou non et si l es poussière n'est pas
positive sur le terrain et autres moyens
évidemment de lutins on en parle tous
les jours contre cette épidémie c'est le
vaccin la panacée en tout le monde
l'attend tous les grands labos sont sur
le coup philippe froguel comment savoir
ce qui va marcher le mieux on a vu que
la russie commence à tester trump qui
nous promet avec ça avant les élections
tout le monde s'y met
est ce que vous êtes optimiste sur ce
point là oui je suis optimiste enfin un
petit peu moins depuis que il ya eu un
effet secondaire grave chez astrazeneca
mais en tout cas pour le vaccin en russe
et tout le monde a moqué eh bien il ya
un article dans le journal de langue 7
qu'est le grand journal mondial est pour
l'instant cet art et sur les essais de
phase 1 et 2 il n'y a pas de vrai gros
problème donc il ya quelques candidats
qui sont en phase iii c'est à dire la
phase où on fait dix mines vingt mille
cinquante mille personnes
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de 48
russe c'est à peu près la même chose en
angleterre ou aux états unis
eh bien j'espère j'espère que s'il n'y a
pas d'effets secondaires dramatique
eh bien on pourra utiliser ces vaccins à
la fin d'année au début de l'année
prochaine
c'est vrai que ça changerait tout jérôme
marty faut que tous les français se
mettaient à lire le long de 7 pour
savoir ce qui est bon ce qui est pas bon
comme quand vaccin parce qu'il ya
peut-être beaucoup de désinformation
aussi là dessus on l'a vu que tu
éclaires dont je crois que si on avait
une si on a une bonne nouvelle pour le
pôle d'auxerre elle sera diffusée sur le
mondial assez rapidement non mais là
dans le problème on parle de poids on
parle d'une pandémie c'est quelque chose
d'assez extraordinaire ça veut dire que
sur la terre entière les hommes
connaissent à un stade plus ou moins
avancé la même problématique ce qui
n'arrive globalement jamais ça veut dire
que si on trouve le vaccin même
structurellement ça va prendre du temps
parce qu'il faut avoir les usines il
faut avoir les hommes il faut avoir les
contenants il faut qu'on produise sur
des milliards d'êtres humains
donc il sait pas c'est pas le tout de le
trouver je crois que le trouve et on le
tour on y arrivera mais structurellement
ça pendant aussi de temps du temps pour
le produire et puis et puis vous avez le
poème de l'égalité je rappelle que la
vie de nos européens vont pas plus que
celle d'un africain que celle de
l'indien donc il va falloir que
l'ensemble de la tête servi en même
temps ça poserait problème
une dernière petite question parce que
le temps file le gouvernement va devoir
prendre des décisions difficiles c'est
ce qu'a déclaré cet après midi le
président du conseil
scientifique gabriela talent qui a
d'ailleurs dit qu' aucune solution
n'était à exclure
ça veut dire quoi philippe froguel qu'on
va nous confiner ça nous pend au nez ça
ça veut dire qu'on est fataliste et que
le gouvernement n'a pas tiré les leçons
de tous les échecs qu'on a depuis
quelques mois alors que on est on est de
très nombreux à dire qu'il faut changer
les choses
faire les tests différemment enfin on
dit on dit à peu près tous les mêmes
choses et je suis vraiment très étonné
une conseil scientifique les boules en
allemand 10 bat ça n'a pas marché et
puis on va être obligé de recombiner ce
que c'est en gros ce que j'ai cru
comprendre à je trouve pas ça très
optimiste nous non plus je remercie
philippe froguel merci jérôme marty
d'avoir accepté ce décryptage ce débat
avec nous en direct sur rt france merci
à vous et la crise sanitaire événement
parmi les sujets phares du séminaire de
rentrée du gouvernement aujourd'hui
autre thème abordé les questions
sécuritaires et le séparatisme
le gouvernement défend son bilan évoque
les recrutements de policiers la hausse
de budget pour le ministère de la
justice pour en parler
donc ça vous avec alexis blanc
éditorialise bonsoir alexis est pour la
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rtl
france alors à la demande du président
de la république le gouvernement tient
manifestement montré qu il se saisit du
thème de l'insécurité
oui ce thème qui a été là tout l'été
avec ces faits divers tragiques de
personnes qui ont perdu la vie ces
scènes d'ultra violence qui inquiète les
français l'insécurité c'est un thème
aussi qui monte quand et bien les
et français les citoyens ont peur de
l'avenir la première fois qu'on parle de
cette violence de cette insécurité du
sentiment d'insécurité 777
peu après le choc pétrolier on commence
les pouvoirs publics commencent à
regarder comment faire alors le
gouvernement a voulu montrer qu'il était
concentré sur ce sujet c'est le sujet de
gérald darmanin depuis plusieurs jours
beaucoup d'effets d'annoncé on attend de
voir ce qu'il va être d'aider des faits
il ya d'une présentation du plan comme
comme vous le disiez l'idée c'est le
continuum sécuritaire c'est donc police
justice comment tout cela peut
fonctionner avec des budgets
supplémentaires 1 milliard pour la
sécurité la rénovation des commissariats
de nouvelles voitures des recrutements
10000 forces de l'ordre et voir comment
est bien faire que police et justice
travaillent ensemble pour que la peine
soit appliquée que les peines soient
proportionnelles et que finalement
l'insécurité baisse le problème de
l'insécurité c'est le sentiment
d'insécurité pour beaucoup de français
c'est une réalité pour beaucoup de
victimes c'est une tragique réalité et
pour d'autres ce sont des chiffres en
faisant les chiffres ne bougent pas donc
la solution de gérald darmanin ces deux
chiffres est à nouveau et de dire on va
revoir la façon dont on calcule dont on
compte le travail des forces de l'ordre
et la réalité de la sécurité
du coup il ya eu une levée de boucliers
de la part des syndicats qui disent que
la politique du chiffre
ils la connaissent ils l'ont fait sous
nicolas sarkozy c'est de la pression de
la part du management et c'est pas
forcément d'une réalité de terrain qui
change à propos de sécurité emmanuel
macron qui revient aujourd'hui justement
sur cette fameuse division dans son
propre camp auquel vous vous faisiez
allusion avec une pirouette si j'ose
dire oui alors il faisait allusion
hilaire le chef de l'état lors de son
déplacement au fameux kama sutra de
l'ensauvagement qui seraient le fait des
médias qui parlerait de l'ensauvagement
davantage que des réalités lui veut
régler les problèmes le vrai problème
c'est pas le kama sutra de
l'ensauvagement c'est le kama sutra du
en même temps comment mêmes acron qu'on
peut faire pour faire travailler
ensemble gérald darmanin à l'intérieur
et eric dupond moretti à la justice on
voit bien ces deux là se sont mis en
scène ces derniers jours se renvoyant la
balle l'un étant pour lens va jouer donc
c'était une réalité l'autre disant que
ça recouvre est totalement quelque chose
de faux
derrière ces deux personnalités
publiques très visible un politique qui
souhaitent faire carrière est allé
beaucoup plus loin gérald darmanin et
dans un poste clé le ministère de
l'intérieur donc il entend bien prendre
ses marques comme nicolas sarkozy
l'avait fait comme manuel valls l'avait
fait avant lui et pour dupont moretti
c'est tout à fait autre chose il donne
des gages sur sa gauche en disant vous
inquiétez pas je suis de gauche donc ce
kama sutra du en même temps il a ses
limites je crois qu'il ya des positions
qu'on ne peut pas tenir et c'était le
cas aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron été obligé de rappeler à
l'ordre ses deux ministres en disant
qu'il ne devait pas mettre en scène la
dissension du gouvernement mais au
contraire mettre en oeuvre la politique
gouvernementale donc peut-être qu'après
ça on les entendra moins sur la justice
on attend ce sera dans les jours qui
viennent qu'on saura quels vont être les
mesures prises et le budget de la
justice
là encore c'est un grand flou encore un
séminaire pour beaucoup parlé et
finalement peu annoncé il y a eu
également la question du séparatisme
au menu également de ce séminaire avec
évidemment toujours le 1er n en ligne de
mire oui et ça c'est extrêmement
critiquée par les députés de la majorité
en marche en disant que s'est donné
beaucoup trop d'importance aux
thématiques du rassemblement national
c'est faire le jeu du rassemblement
national sans être sûr de gagner
cette loi sur le séparatisme les portes
est depuis longtemps un par gérald
darmanin bien avant qu'il soit à ce
poste du ministère de la culture il
avait déjà une position iconoclaste au
sein des républicains il a été casté par
emmanuel macron pour ça pour justement
faire avancer cette loi sur le
séparatisme on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
celui qui a la main qui murmure à
l'oreille des bonnes al-bakr on s'est
davantage gérald darmanin qui fait
avancer tous ces thèmes de manière assez
rapide ans est rentré plus tôt que les
autres ministres qui sont en retrait et
un mot aujourd'hui je pense que certes
l'insécurité est un des thèmes qui
préoccupent les français mais ce qui les
préoccupe davantage comme je le disais
en introduction
c'est l'avenir et c'est l'emploi et de
l'emploi on attend encore une fois de
voir quelles vont être les réalités des
mesures et que peut faire ce
gouvernement sachant que le conseil de
sécurité
de défense sur unis vendredi et qu'on
risque d'avoir des mesures encore
difficile délicate pour l'économie merci
alexis pour avoir été avec nous on
dirait sur rt france restez avec nous
dans quelques instants nous parlerons de
general electric le géant américain
s'apprête à annoncer un plan social
visant les activités françaises de sa
filière d'énergies renouvelables 764
postes seraient menacés puis nous
évoquerons le sommet m fait en corse qui
accueille les sept pays méditerranéens
membres de l'union européenne et
tensions entre la turquie et la grèce
seront au coeur des pourparlers
[Musique]
on donne comberge vous avez découvert
que l'imagerie médicale qui était le
coeur de votre métier avait une
dimension artistique me suis aperçu que
c'était l'art qui faisait avancer la
science et la science qui faisait avant
que celle à l'image est belle mais mais
en général le mal qu'elle révèle
il est terrifiant au moment du coup vite
quand j'ai attrapé bois même la maladie
je me suis dit mais pourquoi j'utilise
pas ma technique de droite et de berton
life a pour mentor axe boat et pour le
virus j'ai pu suivre son évolution comme
henry ça s'aggravait ou au contraire
comment ça s'évacue et quand on a
découvert le coït on sait qu on sait
comment ils et comment
voilà quelle couleur il est qu'on a
découvert le mal l'image du mal
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre 20h30 heure de
paris en direct sur rt france general
electric s'apprête donc à annoncer un
plan social visant les activités
françaises de sa filière d'énergies
renouvelables mille deux cent vingt cinq
postes menacés de suppression en europe
564 rien qu'en france
une nouvelle qui fait désordre alors que
le gouvernement vient lui d'évoquer un
plan de relance destiné à la transition
écologique sur 100 milliards d'euros 30
milliards sont prévus pour le secteur
mais pour le giron américain la france
ne serait plus une priorité dans le
marché de l'énergie le groupe envisage
des délocalisations d'activités en
hongrie en 1 voir en chine
pour en parler nous sommes avec henri
sterdyniak économiste à l'observatoire
français des conjonctures économiques et
bonsoir henri sterdyniak
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france donc nouvelle taille dans les
effectifs ont vu les filières d'énergie
renouvelable du géant américain
très touchée ça fait un petit peu
désordre tout même en pleine relance
verte dans notre pays oui bien sûr le
problème essentiel c'est que la france
est d'ouvrir les gouvernements
successifs ont accepté de vendre des
entreprises à des groupes étrangers et
six groupes étrangers n'ont aucune
raison de de promouvoir l'emploi en
france on s'aperçoit que lorsqu'elle
vous pète ranger dans la main sur ma
propre miss france est très vite
d'entreprise français espère se capacité
de développement et petit à petit
disparaît perspectives d emploi
donc c'est un volet qui vend si on peut
dire dans plan de relève de dans le
temps de relance
il faut défendre des entreprises
françaises contre les prédateurs
étrangers importants on entend le
ministre de l'économie à bruno le maire
nous parlait plus que jamais de
relocalisation industrielle enfin cette
crise du duc au vide où on s'est rendu
compte qu'on avait quelques petites
dépendance ça veut dire qu'en gros notre
pays se tire une balle dans le pied et
celle inverse de ce qu'ils devraient
faire
vous savez que dans plein de 100
milliards bien qu'il ya seulement un
milliard qui est prévu pour les relais
quelles preuves localisation c'est
totalement insuffisant
ce qu'il faut c'est ce qu'il faudrait
augmenter fortement les capacités
d'intervention de bpi france de façon à
ce que des puits france puissent
intervenir de manière offensive pour
empêcher telle ou telle opération
vous savez que les entreprises
françaises manquent de fonds propres
donc elles sont facilement sujet
statiquement victime de prédateurs vous
savez que des directs sion des grandes
entreprises françaises souvent ne se
soucient que de leurs intérêts
personnels et ne défendent pas les leurs
travailleurs et leur entreprise donc il
faudrait que sa chambre au patriotisme
économique et on a un instrument là
dessus qu'ils aient bpi france qui
actuellement est sous-dimensionné et qui
joue pas son rôle
ça veut dire à vous écouter henri
sterdyniak finalement ce patriotisme
économique il passe nécessairement par
une forme de subvention de l'économie
française dans un premier temps il faut
la mettre sous perfusion de façon à ce
qu'elles puissent ensuite marchait de
ses propres poèmes ne dirais pas qu'il
faut la mettre sur perfusion mais il
faut lui fournir des fonds propres
c'est ce qui manque les entreprises
françaises des parents histoire
on connaît les nationalisations les
privatisations qui sont fait un peu
n'importe comment
manque plus généralement de fonds
propres et donc il faut avoir des
actionnaires de référence
les actionnaires de référence ce doit
être l'état français avec le souci de
développer l'industrie en france
mais tant qu'on a pas sa longue barbe
continuer à voir les pépites de demain
industrie disparaître petit à petit
parce qu'elle se racheter par des
entreprises étrangères qui disposent de
fonds propres plus importantes et qui ne
se souvient me soucie absolument pas de
la cohérence de l'industrie française
alors appel quand même le contexte des
plans sociaux qui interviennent cinq ans
après le rachat des activités énergie
alstom un chat sauf erreur de ma part
qui ont été clairement validé par le
ministre de l'économie de l'époque un
certain emmanuel macron c'est l'ironie
du sort aujourd'hui ce constat d'une
très lourde de responsabilités du manie
le bâton dans cette dans cette aventure
cette acceptation qu entend
effectivement une filiale d'une
entreprise une entreprise américaine
avec des garanties qui se sont révélés
totalement illusoire sans compter les
cymbales fermeture du site de belfort à
un lourd symbole 1 89 anciens salariés
d'alstom ont concerné oui le symbole les
la disparition de la cge de la cjr le
fait qu effectivement on avait une
entreprise performante au niveau
européen au niveau mondial et que petit
à petit cette entreprise a été
démantelée parce que les actionnaires
français comme la direction nous sommes
souci de sauvegarder ce fleuron de notre
industrie
pour quelles raisons tout simplement
pour des raisons financières de pur
profit est ce que c'est aussi simple que
cela
ils ont ce qui est crucial
actuellement pour une entreprise c'est
de disposer de fonds propres et
d'actionnaire de référence c'est-à-dire
de la capacité effectivement à se
protéger des prédateurs étrangers
lorsqu'on n'a pas cette capacité on est
victime on est menacé les
entreprise étrangère promettent des
ponts d'or ou dirigeants des entreprises
menacées ils promettent de racheter à
des taux à des prix intéressants aux
anciens actionnaires qui les uns comme
les autres ne se soucient que de leurs
intérêts de court terme et on arrive à
la catastrophe que revoir dans le cas de
deux alstom et en plus on n'avait pas on
n'a toujours pas au niveau du
gouvernement la volonté effectivement de
protéger les entreprises françaises
lorsqu'on a un président de la
république qui jadis qui est de la
guerre travaillait dans les opérations
de haut de bilan
c'est généralement des opérations qui se
font contre les entreprises et non pas
pour les entreprises
on le voit encore cette semaine avec la
tentative de veolia de s'emparer de ce
fait c'est pas me c'est pas intéressant
du point de vue industriel
le risque c'est effectivement ça va se
faire parce que les actionnaires d'
angie toucheront 1 ou plus de lui merci
henri sterdyniak d'avoir été avec nous
avoir apporté votre analyse et au chant
également qui annonce la suppression de
1400 75 postes en france un plan pour
adapter aux nouvelles attentes des
consommateurs et des citoyens
le groupe nordiste prévoit par ailleurs
la création de 3 177 postes
le distributeur français a lancé l'an
passé un plan baptisé auchan 2022 qui
vise à transformer en profondeur son
offre et qui devrait lui permettre de
réaliser des économies de l'ordre de 1,1
milliard d'euros et des pertes d'emplois
en pagaille c'est ce qui attend les
salariés du sous traitant également
aéronautique 3a dans toute la france en
grève les employés du site de méaulte
dans la somme se bat aujourd'hui pour
partir dans de bonnes conditions
renault parquet avec grégoire douce et
un plan de sauvegarde de l'emploi jugés
insatisfaisants
avec la crise du coronavirus la société
d'assistance aéronautique aérospatiale
a vu son chiffre d'affaires chuter 3 a
lancé un plan national de licenciements
sur les sites de méaulte carquefou et
toulouse conséquence un pse lourd à
encaisser rien qu à méaulte 139 des 150
postes devraient être supprimés
si les salariés concernés semblent
résignés à l'idée de perdre leur emploi
ils se battent pour obtenir un départ
honorable à des conditions supérieures
au minimum légal qui leur est proposée
par le ps pour l'instant
et prêt prévoit le minimum légal en fait
en tout point que ce soit en congé de
reconversion que ce soit en prime de
licenciement qu il prévoit le minimum
légal
aujourd'hui un salarié chez nous partir
avec 500 euros d'annuités ce qui est la
loi donc présent par année d'ancienneté
en tout cas et donc donc c'est
intolérable on est dans dans on est on a
travaillé depuis 10 15 ans avec dans
l'entreprise et on estime qu'on a c'est
qu'on doit quitte à partir puisque s'il
crise sanitaire ya des difficultés il ya
on peut peut-être l'entendre mais on
doit partir pour pouvoir se replacer
correctement et pour pouvoir avoir un
avenir et c'est simplement ce que les
salariés demandent aujourd'hui quatre
mois de formation équivalent à 3500
euros trop peu pour pouvoir se remettre
en selle selon la cfdt qui plus est dans
le contexte actuel est loin d'être
favorable à l'industrie aéronautique
les travailleurs réclament des
indemnités équivalant à deux mois de
salaire par année d'ancienneté ils
s'estiment floués par la direction d'une
entreprise pour laquelle ils ont
consacré plusieurs années de leur vie
sur les 1500 89 salariés et 800
intérimaires
le plan de sauvegarde de l'emploi
prévoit de supprimer 7 119 postes au
niveau national et on en vient à présent
à ce rapport de 176 pages sur la fraude
aux prestations sociales en france
publié aujourd'hui par la cour des
comptes
et cette conclusion même si elle existe
bel et bien les magistrats se sont dit
incapable de chiffrer cette fraude faute
d'éléments suffisants important des
chiffres circulent on parle parfois de
milliards d'euros selon la haute
juridiction il faut changer d'échelle et
identifier les potentiels fraudeurs en
amont et pour philippe muray économie
ces fraudes sont non due en partie à un
certain laxisme des organismes de
prestations sociales
c'est une erreur évidente qui a été fait
par les élites de notre pays c'est de
tout dématérialisé
quand vous commencez vous vous inscrivez
la sécurité sociale ou encore ou à la
route voilà par exemple une autre
prestation sociale
maintenant vous pouvez le faire avec des
documents dans voyant par internet des
documents et des copies de documents
il est évident que c'est beaucoup moins
efficace que d'avoir une personne sur
place qui a obligé de se déplacer qui va
montrer ses différents papiers de
d'identité ces différents documents sur
lequel on pourra beaucoup plus
facilement repérer une fraude que des
envois par internet
et puis il faut aussi des détecteurs de
faux documents donc il faut beaucoup de
contrôle face à face notamment des
retraités à l'étranger je vous imaginez
bien il ya beaucoup de retraités la
lettre qui sont payés à l'étranger
d'après le document de la cour des
comptes ya 7 millions de cette retraitée
pays à l'étranger ce qui est
complètement incompréhensible qu'il ya
12 millions de retraités français et
donc on se retrouve avec quelque chose
de qui ne va pas parce qu'il ya pas
assez de contrôleurs aussi demain aura
lieu le sommet m 7 en corse qui réunira
sept pays méditerranéens membres de
l'union européenne de nombreux sujets
prévus au programme avec une attention
toute particulière aux tensions entre la
turquie et la grèce théo combat un
sommet sous le soleil corse qui
s'annonce brûlant emmanuel macron
accueille ce jeudi le médecin est ce
forum informel composé de sept pays a
été lancée en 2016 dans un contexte de
fracture entre les états du nord de
l'europe et ceux du sud sur fond de
crise économique grecque
un groupe qui se réunit pour la première
fois en france dans un climat de tension
en méditerranée orientale
objectif que les pays de cette alliance
également membre de l'union européenne
fasse front commun avant la prochaine
réunion des 27 sur la question dans le
contexte des tensions méditerranée
orientale
il s'agit de faire progresser le
consensus sur les relations de l'union
européenne avec la turquie en vue
notamment du sommet européen des 24 et
25 septembre qui sera consacrée depuis
plusieurs semaines la question de la
recherche et de la propriété des
gisements d'hydrocarbures provoque une
véritable escalade de saillies verbales
et de démonstration de force entre la
république hellénique et chypre d'un
côté et la turquie de l'autre athènes et
nicosie dénonce les prospections turque
dans d autres que les deux capitales et
tim relever de leur souveraineté des
accusations jugées comme nuls et non
avenus
par ankara notre pays comme vous le
savez outre l'agression fait face à des
actions de la turquie qui conteste
toutes les règles de la charte des
nations unies la turquie porte une
rhétorique qui déforment l'histoire
échange de géographie sapant la légalité
et les actions qui mettent en danger la
sécurité dans toute la méditerranée
[Musique]
ce n'est pas sincère
les pays de l'union européenne sont
lassés par la grèce car elle tient en
otage des relations turquie union
européenne tout le monde dit que la
grèce a tort du point de vue du droit
international
un dossier majeur pour emmanuel macron
particulièrement impliqué depuis le
début de cette crise le président
français a affirmé au cours des
dernières semaines son soutien à ses
homologue chypriote et grecque
déployant même plusieurs bâtiments de
guerre dans la zone concernée de la
réunion du med 7 ne devrait durer que
quelques heures mais pourrait permettre
de rassurer athènes et nicosie
quant au soutien des pays méditerranéens
membres de l'union européenne
et pour en parler nous sommes avec à
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude mais
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous
alors qu'elle est tout d'abord l'origine
de ce sommet pour bien qu'on comprenne
les choses se former un petit peu
insolite à cette remonte en fait au
monde d'avant c'est à dire avant la
pandémie avant la crise économique qui
s'en est suivie et aussi avant le
prendre dans le plan de relance de
l'union européenne il s'agissait pour la
grèce pour l'italie pour l'espagne
d'améliorer leurs mains dans les
discussions avec les pays du nord à
bruxelles puisque était axé d'appartenir
au club med aux pays méditerranéens avec
ce que cela implique et dans la dans la
désignation et que les pays du nord
était rigoureux sur le plan budgétaire
tout ceci a changé avec l'adoption lors
du dernier conseil européen d'un plan de
relance là tu fait que l'allemagne avait
dans le fond réalisé que son intérêt
bien compris
était de soutenir ce plan de relance est
de venir au secours des pays du sud les
plus impactés par la crise donc
aujourd'hui à l'époque que bien sûr la
grèce il ya quatre ans avait invité les
six autres pays
donc la france et l'italie l'espagne et
le portugal chypre et malte et la france
dans le fond trouver un intérêt dans ce
dans ce genre de rencontre puisque elle
appartenait à la fois aux pays
méditerranéens dont elle pouvait être le
leader et se faire le porte parole
auprès de l'allemagne dont elle était le
partenaire privilégié à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne
aujourd'hui le contexte est complètement
différent puisque comme vient de le
montrer votre sujet dont on ne peut pas
parler de méditerranée sans parler de
turquie et sans parler de sécurité
et effectivement ce sera probablement le
sujet de discussion majeur mais les
chefs d'état de gouvernement parleront
aussi de migration parlerons aussi
d'économie parleront aussi de sujets
d'intérêt commun
autre que la turquie justement à cette
turquie que peut-on en attendre de ce
sommet par rapport aux cas turc alors il
s'agit comme yann cela vient d'être dit
dans votre sujet de préparer le conseil
européen des 24 et 25 septembre qui à
son menu les relations entre l'union
européenne et la turquie la turquie
n'est pas les lui l'union européenne
d'ailleurs la turquie étant en situation
de d'union douanière avec l'union
européenne
il ya des accords très anciens des
accords économiques très anciens entre
l'union européenne et la turquie
simplement évidemment le comportement de
la turquie fait que depuis un certain
temps les négociations d'une éventuelle
adhésion de la turquie sont gelés alors
je pense qu'en effet on confirmera ce
gel peut être même certains états
membres dont la france devront qu'au
bout du compte il faut être réaliste et
que la turquie n'a pas vocation à
adhérer à l'union européenne
même à long terme il se peut que demain
à ajaccio des pays comme l'italie est
comme l'espagne refuse de le dire
ouvertement parce que l'italie et
l'espagne ont toujours été favorables à
une grande politique méditerranéenne
de l'union européenne et une grande
politique méditerranéenne de l'union
européenne
ça comporte aussi la turquie est un
dialogue avec la turquie
donc il est tout à fait probable que
demain on insistera sur la nécessité
d'un dialogue entre la grèce et la
turquie
bien sûr les participants étant
solidaire des membres de l'union
européenne qui sont là c'est à dire
c'est à dire la grèce et chypre elle la
france elle en tout cas dépouillés à des
navires de guerre et des avions de
combat dans la région pour soutenir la
grèce mais ce qu'elle est partie peu
isolé oui je crois que la position de la
france est claire elle à elle a indiqué
que que la position et les différentes
politiques poursuivis par la turquie
n'était pas acceptable et il ya beaucoup
de sujets y compris l'action de la delà
de la turquie en libye vous savez qu'un
navire français un navire militaire
français a été sous le feu comme on dit
des radars turcs parce qu'il voulait
contrôler la cargaison d'un cargo turc
jeu conformément d'ailleurs aux
décisions de l'onu
puisqu'il ya un embargo sur la livraison
d'armes et que tout le monde sait que la
turquie livre les d'armes gouvernement
de tripoli
il est probablement d'ailleurs pas la
seule puisque d'autres livres les larmes
hommage à la star
toujours est il que il ya eu cette
rencontre agressive entre deux navires
de guerre français et turcs et que
depuis cette époque en effet le
président macron demande que la turquie
s'explique et peut-être même que l'on
décide de sanctions à l'égard de la
turquie
là-dessus l'union européenne est divisée
et cette division sera aussi refléter
demain au groupe des sept états
méditerranéens de l'union européenne
parce que encore une fois l'italie et
l'espagne considère que mieux vaut
dialoguer que d'imposer des sanctions
donc il est probable qu'on se retrouvera
avec ce débat en l'état au conseil
européen et l'otan dans tout ça
l'otan n'a pas grand chose à voir avec
la réunion de demain puisque deux pays
qui participeront à la réunion en corse
ne sont pas membres de l'otan
chypre et malte ne sont pas membres de
l'otan alors mal parce que mal de s'est
déclaré neutre et chypre parce que
d'abord c'est un état qui est dans une
situation particulière avec un conflit
que personne n'était capable de régler
depuis 1974 lorsque les militaires turcs
ont envahi le nord de l'île
beaucoup de tentatives ont été faites à
l'onu est ailleurs et ses tentatives ont
finalement échoué
le fait que le nord de l'île de chypre
sont occupées par un régime propres aux
turcs qui n'est reconnu par personne
sauf par la turquie est d'ailleurs un
des problèmes parce qu'évidemment il a
une zone qui est sa mère territoriale il
a une zone économique et que dans cette
zone la turquie entend bien faire des
recherches pétrolières
or ce cette partie nord de chypre
ayant constitué un état que personne ne
reconnaît évidemment tout ce qui se
passe dans sa zone maritime est illégal
aux yeux du droit de la mer
suivant la convention de monterrey et
des nations unies et puis ça n'est pas
fini parce que la turquie fait
évidemment des recherches pétrolières un
peu partout dans des zones qui sont
contestées entre la grèce et la turquie
dont il faudrait déterminer exactement
la ligne de partage des eaux là la grèce
ayant des îles très proche de la côte
turque évident considère que toute cette
zone maritime et sous sa juridiction
la turquie elle joue le jeu du plateau
continental ou de l'équidistance par
rapport aux côtes
et effectivement on a un différend très
important qui devait heures et qui
s'aggrave et qui va s'aggraver et puis
il y aura ensuite un autre sujet de
conflit qui sera le gazoduc eux venant
d'israël passant par chip pour aller en
grèce par conséquent beaucoup de
conflits au menu des relations avec la
turquie qu'il faut essayer de déminer et
pour le moment l'otan n'y a pas réussi
peut-être l'union européenne
il réussira t-elle merci
et claude blanchemaison la question en
tout cas restent en suspens dans
quelques instants nous parlerons du
séminaire de rentrée du gouvernement
avec les questions sécuritaires et de
séparatisme au menu et puis direction en
afghanistan où le vice-président était
visé par une attaque qui a tué au moins
dix personnes à kaboul
[Musique]
le troisième mandat d'alassane ouattara
ce n'était pas prévu amadou gon
coulibaly était le candidat choisi à
l'unanimité donc des cadres du rhdp
malheureusement lui j'ai amadou gon
coulibaly est décédé pourquoi
aujourd'hui le président et candidat à
sa propre succession
nous estimons que l'opposant ouattara
est celui qui a le leadership nécessaire
pour faire face au public se pose à nous
tant au niveau interne ou externe qui
m'a particulier en ce moment on peut
d'ivoire et des violences sous prétexte
d'une manifestation et d'expression de
droit démocratique
on incite à la haine on estime m est-ce
que sincèrement vous êtes certains que
le scrutin du 31 octobre sera maintenu à
la date prévue
il n'y a pas de raison que ce scrutin ne
soit pas maintenu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
en pleine crise du coroner virus après
avoir constaté l'incapacité de l'union
européenne à manifester la moindre
solidarité envers des etam l'europe
une fois de plus est en crise la montée
en puissance de la chine dans le
commerce mondial a évidemment réduit le
poids de l'euro il faut y ajouter la
fragmentation de la zone et son
incapacité à parler d'une seule voix la
rend beaucoup moins attractif
il est évident que le projet politique
d'une véritable union est mort entre des
membres trop différent est trop long la
vraie question est de savoir si le
président français va vouloir et pouvoir
rebondir et comment les choix sont
multiples mais tout le problème va être
de bien choisir
[Musique]
accueillis au cambodge qui fait si vous
au combat
instituteur vous avez ici un emploi qui
vous satisfait en somme
c'est grâce en fait l entraide dans sa
communauté que mes parents ont pu
retrouver un travail trouver aussi un
appartement ou revivre le besoin de
réussir est l'un des buts principaux du
migrants chinois
il est clair que c'est une communauté à
travers laquelle on ne voit pas et qu'il
est très difficile de pénétrer et où ne
sais pas ce qui s'y passe en politique
on commence à voir quelques visages
d'origine asiatique mais je trouve que
ça manque encore ça manque notamment
dans les médias à la télévision qui
sommes nous aujourd'hui dans cette
société française et comment peut-on en
fait vivre en harmonie avec cette
diversité on dit tout simplement une
chose indique t on au français
[Musique]
votre gouvernement et notre gouvernement
ainsi que tous les autres grands
gouvernements du monde savent ce qui va
se passer et quand ça va se passer a
rendu mais ne nous ont pas dit et ils ne
me l'ont pas dit matière vous pouvez
imaginer quelque chose de si grands que
la terre faire ça cela va provoquer les
raz-de-marée des tremblements de terre
les éruptions
la terre va s'incliner ça va être payant
c'est le col de mon grand père personne
ne se soucierait des lois ou d'aller en
prison
illégalité prospérerait et la vie
deviendrait insupportable une ballerine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle jean biart j'ai 18 ans je
crois en effet d'entraînement
on va leur enseigner leur show c'est
l'école d'arts martiaux du temple de
shaolin
et le ça fait trois fois que je te le
dis tu ne comprends pas où tu vas
t'entraîner tout seul
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
encore une fois c'est pas bon comme si
c'était la première fois en jetons à se
tourner encore les filles le font mieux
croit en toi et tu réussiras
[Musique]
et
l'eau
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité mais idée courageuse
des mots qui compte on soit vient de
grignan aujourd'hui la gauche extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre pour cette deuxième
partie d'émission il est 21h heure de
paris voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce mercredi 9 septembre à la crise
sanitaire parmi les sujets phares du
séminaire de rentrée du gouvernement
aujourd'hui
autre thème abordé les questions
sécuritaires et le séparatisme
le gouvernement défend son bilan et
évoque les recrutements de policiers et
la hausse de budget pour le ministère de
la justice
donald trump devrait annoncer
prochainement des retraits d'afghanistan
où les états unis disposent de 8600
militaire annonce d'un haut responsable
de l'administration alors qu'une
nouvelle attaque à kaboul a tué au moins
dix personnes
la confiance ébranlée entre le royaume
uni et l'union européenne dans le cadre
du brds excite le gouvernement
britannique a publié le projet de loi
controversé révisant l'accord en
violation assumé du droit international
l'union européenne elle demande des
explications l'irlande parle d'un acte
kamikaze ce sera l'objet de notre face à
face
[Musique]
le gouvernement s'est réuni aujourd'hui
pour plancher sur le thème de
l'insécurité à la demande d' emmanuel
macron la multiplication des agressions
en france a replacé l'insécurité comme
deuxième sujet de préoccupation des
français
après l'épidémie de kovy 19 écouter le
porte parole du gouvernement gabriela
tabou - pas à rougir de ce qui a été le
portait depuis 2017
je rappelle le milliard en plus pour le
budget n'est sécurité le recrutement
engagés de 10000 forces de police et de
gendarmerie
le paiement des heures supplémentaires
des policiers dont on parlait depuis des
années qu'ils n'avaient pas été honorées
la l'augmentation de la rémunération
nette de nos forces de sécurité et puis
encore tout récemment le renouvellement
du parc automobile de nos forces de
l'ordre autant de mesures extrêmement
complète concrètes sur ce plan de la
sécurité
nous allons poursuivre dans le cadre de
la présentation du projet de loi de
finances une augmentation du budget du
ministère de la justice a été annoncée
par le premier ministre
mais pour en parler nous sommes avec
jean-pierre colombiès porte parole de
l'association de l'union des policiers
nationaux indépendants
bonsoir jean pierre colombiès merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france on viens de l'entendre gabriela
attal qui défend farouchement le bilan
du gouvernement il évoque les
recrutements de nouveaux policiers les
heures supplémentaires payées en gros
personne n'avait jamais été jusque là
votre réaction
en réaction elle est un petit peu
désabusé oui bien évidemment qu'ils ne
vont pas ils vont pas s'auto flageller
et critiquer leurs actions au bout de
trois ans d'ailleurs il faut pas il faut
pas faire un faux procès d'intention ou
gouvernement actuel la situation dont il
hérite
elle ne date pas d'hier elle est le
résultat de plus de 20 ans de retrait
des forces de sécurité d'une grande
partie du territoire et il faudra
beaucoup plus par contre que ddd fait
des effets d'annoncé comme ceux auquel
riyad assister vous savez de le milliard
qui est avancé il faudrait voir plus en
détail si on n'assiste pas pour plutôt
un glissement de budget d'un budget à
l'autre et surtout à quoi ça a loué ce
milliard peut-être tout simplement au
paiement dix ans
plémentaires du reste ce sera ce sera
loin très loin de suffire pour combler
le déficit logistique dont souffre la
police tente au niveau immobilier qu'au
niveau des véhicules qu au niveau 2 de
l'informatique enfin il ya tellement de
choses qui sont en déshérence depuis
très longtemps il faudra pas se
contenter de deux bouts de rustines
pareil pour les dix mille dix mille
fonctionnaires dont on annonce le
recrutement est ce qu'il s'agit d'un
véritable renfort d'un ajout à des
défenses existantes ou est-ce qu'on est
tout simplement dans le cadre d'un
recrutement déjà programmé faut se
méfier des effets d annonce comme je
lisais on est dans une situation
catastrophique
il ya des commissariats dans ce pays
qu'ils sont en état de mort cérébrale il
ya quasiment plus de fonctionnaires pour
faire tourner la boutique pour pouvoir
les curieux affluent
donc voila quoi il faudra aller bien au
delà des déclarations de va-t-en-guerre
avec l'assurance durée de la volonté
inébranlable d'un gouvernement dont
d'ailleurs la colonne vertébrale
sécuritaire n'est pas n'est pas lisible
il faudrait vraiment savoir veut aller
ce gouvernement en matière de sécurité
le lien notamment entre la citoyenneté
et sa police
et au passage il faut vraiment tout le
monde et en conscience que quelle que
soit la politique sécuritaire décidé par
quelques ministres de l'intérieur que ce
soit il ne peut pas aboutir sans une
collaboration étroite avec le ministère
de la justice sur n'a pas conscience de
ça sont purement et simplement des
déclarations de principe ça veut dire
quoi concrètement évidemment vous faites
allusion voilà aux bisbilles entre le
garde des sceaux et le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin eric dupond
moretti vous pensez que c'est un un
mauvais duo en tout cas pas l'un et
l'autre pris séparément mais que ce duo
ne pourra pas fonctionner ça vous ça
vous inquiète justement vous savez nous
mais mais je ne suis pas sûr doit dire
monsieur m houleux
schultz ministre eric dupond-moretti
aujourd'hui mais nommée du goût du
combat eric dupond-moretti ministre de
la justice on voit bien que c'est
purement et simplement une provocation
après qu'est ce que ça cache qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que ce qu'est ce que l'on
veut faire et ce que l'on a procédé à
ces nominations de personnalités
tellement clivante tellement différente
pour détourner l'attention de l'opinion
publique et s'occuper d'autre chose par
ailleurs assez probable c'est un
scénario qui n'est pas du tout incongru
moi j'attends rien et j'attends rien de
ça très concrètement j'attends rien
parce que à l'évidence il n'y a pas de
volonté ni chez la niche et l'autre de
déclencher de mettre en place des
réformes de fond des réformes profondes
par exemple on pourrait songer à la
dynamisation du d'une filière juridique
du judiciaire avec une vraie refonte des
services mais là ça nécessiterait
beaucoup d'ambitions beaucoup moyens
beaucoup d'honnêteté morale aussi parce
que ça obligerait certains très
corporatistes à renoncer à leur acquis
et à faire fi de leurs états d'âme
on en est loin on en est très loin on
est dans une dans des guerres d'ego on
est dans des guerres d'individus de
personnalités qui ont leur profil et on
sent pas une véritable volonté de
résoudre les problèmes d'intérêts
généraux et j'ai des grands plans mais
il n'ya pas grave que ça peut-être tout
simplement un manque
voilà une différence total de
philosophie entre entre ces deux
ministres quand l'un parle dans son
ouvrage sur l'autre
le nid ça veut dire en gros qu'un un qui
pense nommer un problème qui existe loki
l'autre qui finalement est dans une
forme
certains diraient de dénis oui mais là
j'ai envie de vous dire que on est à
deux on joue un poker menteur je suis
pas certain que ni l'un ni l'autre n'ont
véritablement ni envie ni les moyens de
régler les problèmes et des défis qui
sont qui sont en face à aux politiques
actuelles bon dupond-moretti on sait
très bien de qui il s'agit c'est un
avocat c'est pas un défenseur des
libertés publiques c'était c'est un
homme qui a défendu des clients il a
défendu des clients n'a pas défendu des
principes et monsieur darmanin est un
homme qui a été élevé si je puis dire
dans le cercle du sarkozysme donc à une
certaine époque où
on l'apprenait de manière exagérée la
politique du résultat au détriment d'une
efficacité relationnel sur le terrain
donc j'ai envie de vous dire que ni l'un
ni l'autre de toute façon ne résoudront
ne résoudrons le moindre problème
c'est une question de personnalité de
personnes c'est un fait mais c'est aussi
comme je dis je le répète ou
problématiques de vision sécuritaire il
n'y en a pas il n'y en a pas on n'a pas
l'intention de changer de société on
arrive à quelque chose qui soit qui ne
soit plus justement le du ressort du
pouvoir régalien
on veut y substituer des pouvoirs de
police municipale voire de sociétés
privées donc que vous ayez monsieur dans
l'ain où dupont moretti à la justice à
changera pas grand chose si il faudrait
vraiment réfléchir à ça à savoir ce que
monsieur macro plus tôt a derrière la
tête lorsqu il nomme des personnalités
comme celle ci que tout oppose et au
final voyez le débat tourne autour de ça
finalement on se demande s'ils vont
finir par s'entendre mais on ne pose pas
la question de savoir quelle est leur
vision de la société de demain
alors il ya une curiosité également en
ce moment eric dupond moretti qui nous
dit que les chiffres voilà de la
violence n'ont pas augmenté et puis à le
fameux ressenti un petit peu comme la
météo
quel est votre avis de deux policiers là
tu es ce que oui et non la violence
selon vous selon le policier que vous
êtes a augmenté en france
elle s'est surtout banalisé et elle
s'est surtout développée sans aucun
risque de pénalités c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui des gens commettent de façon
régulière des actes de violence sans
qu'ils encourent la moindre peine de
prison effective jeudi bien effective
parce que contrairement à ce qu'a dit
monsieur dupont moretti
c'est pas vrai que 92% des peines sont
sont appliquées c'est faux
quelqu'un qui est condamné à un an de
prison ferme ne les fera pas tout
simplement parce que il ya des barèmes
il y à il ya des curseurs en deçà
desquels on devra tout simplement pas
incarcérer des individus donc vous avez
des gens qui se sont installés depuis
très longtemps maintenant dans une
dynamique de délinquance dont ils n'ont
absolument pas envie de sortir
c'est pour ça que ce débat est tronqué
d'ailleurs par ailleurs on met en avant
le chômage la précarité sociale c'est
fou ces fouilles et des gens qui sont
tout simplement installé dans le système
de la délinquance comme moyens
d'existence normal donc il faudra bien
autre chose pour je dirais non pas les
faire revenir dans le droit chemin s'ils
n'ont pas du tout envie mais pour les
neutraliser
donc on n'est pas du tout dans du
ressenti là c'est une réalité
la violence elle est là bon c'est sûr
que si on compare la situation de
criminels de la france où dix neuvième
siècle par rapport à aujourd'hui
c'est sans commune mesure ce serait
d'ailleurs stupide de jouer à ce petit
jeu là mais il ya aujourd'hui c'est fait
une banalisation de la violence et de la
délinquance qui est devenu tout à fait
qu'on compte qu'on passe notre temps à
excuser a légitimé à a tenté de
neutraliser médiatiquement s'entend mais
pas du tout de neutraliser juridiquement
non loin la banalisation de la violence
contre la police également et vice versa
diraient certains de vos détracteurs
coûté la violence contre les policiers à
ma connaissance n'est pas toujours suivi
d'incarcération ça c'est un fait
ensuite moi par contre lorsque des faits
de violence sont avérés contre des
policiers je défends pas tous louent
attention kompass vous pas se méprendre
sur ce que je vais vous dire lorsque des
faits de violences ou des fautes graves
son sang sont avérés les policiers sont
poursuivis et pour beaucoup sont
révoqués donc il est faux aussi de faire
croire ou de laisser croire qu'il ya une
impunité totale des actes de violences
policières après que le système soit un
parfait on va pas dire le contraire
ces derniers mois il ya une dérive dans
l'utilisation des forces de maintien de
l'ordre
on a glissé vers des méthodologies
d'emploi des forces de sécurité sur le
terrain qui sont très discutables
là encore ça répondait à une volonté
politique faut pas se font pas se
leurrer et donc il faut il faudra
réfléchir à tout ça et là je mets en
garde
je mets en garde sur le flip bashing et
sur le fait que j'étais une institution
avec l'eau du bain se serait pas une
bonne idée
ce sont ces la philosophie globale il
faut changer qu'il faut adapter
en d'autres termes mettre les politiques
devant leurs responsabilités avant toute
chose et pas simplement s'attarder à des
photos
duel sur le terrain je n'aurais pas
attaques sont pas du tout excusable dans
certains cas pour d'autres c'est
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus sujet à
discussion mais faut que chacun soit
face à ses responsabilités
et là j invite à ce que cette
responsabilité soit réellement posée au
niveau des donneurs d'ordres ne sera pas
mal merci beaucoup jean-pierre
colombienne c'est en tout cas d'avoir
été avec nous nous avoir apporté votre
point de vue est toujours en france avec
le prochain procès est chargé en
émotions des attentats de janvier 2015
après les témoignages hier des
survivants de la tuerie de charlie hebdo
les familles des victimes sont entendus
aujourd'hui par la cour spéciale de
paris et précision sur place de notre
reporter katia technique
la journée a été consacrée aux
témoignages des survivants et le procès
a pris un tour politique celui qu'on
attendait car au delà des méfaits des
accusés ce profit d'une question parce
que la liberté est menacée par le
fanatisme religieux évidemment pour
toutes ces survivants la réponse est oui
tout à l'heure laurent sourisseau d'iris
a évoqué cette journée de massacre il
était venu pour tous nous tuer at-il
appuyé
il explique au fil des années ce n'est
pas charlie qui a changé mais qui l'a vu
se profiler des obscurantismes et de
nouvelles formes de totalitarisme
ça pose une vraie question est ce qu'un
journal comme charlie hebdo 1 va
disparaître à cause du terrorisme dans
un pays comme la france at il questionné
est ce qu'on vit pour être libre ou être
esclave est un combat pour la liberté
pour la laïcité finalement il a dit si
notre génération n'est pas capable de
faire ça eh bien j'ai honte de notre
génération
à ce sujet je vous proposais côté
richard malka l'avocat de charlie hebdo
c'est le récit de
la souffrance d'hommes de femmes et
c'était c'était particulièrement
émouvant mais mais ça c'est la
conséquence d'un massacre du fanatisme
de la bêtise aussi mémé la cause on a
commencé à en parler ce matin avec
fabrice nicolino et puis et puis la
crise est la cause
la cause c'est celle des caricatures de
2006 je les ai montré pendant la salle
d'audience et c'est cette malheureuse
caricature ou en réalité je veux leur
montrer parce qu'il faut la montrer aux
jeunes générations faut savoir pourquoi
on a tué des âmes et des femmes parce
qu'on a un mahomet et pleuré pleuré
d'être soutenus par des intégristes
ce qui veut bien dire que mahomet et du
côté des non intégristes également à la
barre patrick pelloux médecin urgentiste
et collaborateurs de charlie hebdo il
est arrivé juste après le massacre et il
a organisé le sauvetage de ses amis
blessés
il a évoqué un désespoir au quotidien
des larmes dans la voix elle était
extrêmement ému il a dénoncé certains
qui à gauche confondent défense de la
laïcité et racisme
personne n'empêche de croire mais ne
nous empêchait pas de penser je vous
propose de l'écouter
j'attends plus de l'état de la classe
politique pour défendre la laïcité
charb défendent est la laïcité ce
journal défend toujours la laïcité et
c'est quand même un petit peu fort que
des intellectuels des journalistes
retourne la laïcité en disant si vous
défendez la laïcité c'est que vous êtes
raciste c'est pas du tout ça on en passe
on n'empêche personne de croire en le
dieu qui veulent l'islamisme est un
fascisme oui oui vous avez qu'à voir ce
qu'a fait des ch
ce café des ch en syrie quand vous
regardez ce qui se passe avec al qaïda
maghreb vous apercevez que 80% des
victimes de l'islamisme ce sont des
musulmans et c'est une réalité
terrorisme islamiste
il n'a battra jamais notre république on
sera toujours plus fort que voilà et je
pleure mes amis morts tous les jours
mais voilà on est là tous ces
journalistes engagés parmi eux fabrice
nicolino également ont dénoncé un
totalitarisme islamique
voici pour cette journée des témoignages
de survivants
riche en émotions et les chants prises
de position et je vous propose d'écouter
le témoignage de zineb el rhazoui ex
journaliste de charlie hebdo également
présente à cette audience
je suis venu dire que quand on vit
accompagné d'hommes armés c'est qu'on
dit avec le sentiment que l'assassin
court toujours
et cet assassin il s'appelle le
terrorisme islamique
il a continué à sévir en france après
les attentats de charlie hebdo il a fait
des centaines de victimes et ils
menacent encore et c'est aussi le procès
de cet assassin là que je veux faire ce
procès des attentats de janvier 2015
n'est pas un procès de droit commun
c'est un procès politique et idéologique
quel était le mobile du crime si ce
n'est l'idéologie cette idéologie on en
est où par rapport à ça en france est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on exerce notre liberté
d'expression en france
est ce qu'il ya un journal qui oserait
publier quelque chose qui fâche ray les
islamistes c'est légal de le faire mais
faites le à vos risques et périls
en tout cas moi je prends le risque
tous les jours de dénoncer ça parce que
c'était ça qu'on faisait à charlie et le
sang qui a coulé il a coulé pour cette
cause là et cette cause là il faut
continuer à la défendre
le président américain donald trump a
tient l'une de ses promesses de campagne
il devrait annoncer prochainement de
nouveaux retraits de soldats américains
présents en afghanistan
c'est ce qu'a indiqué un haut
responsable de l'administration on le
rappelle
les etats unis disposent encore de 8600
militaires sur le territoire afghan
l'actuel location locataire de la maison
blanche ne cesse de le répéter il veut
se désengager je cite des guerres sans
fin et c'est donc dans ce contexte que
s'est déroulé ce matin un nouvel
attentat à kaboul au moins dix personnes
ont été tuées lors d'une attaque à la
bombe visant le convoi
donc on voit damrau la salle et premier
vice-président afghan connu pour son
hostilité envers les talibans de leur
côté des états unis devrait donc
annoncer le retrait de soldats encore
présents dans le pays françois xavier
lambert une épaisse colonne de fumée
s'élève dans le ciel de kaboul à nouveau
la capitale afghane vient d'être frappé
par un attentat
et cette fois ci c'est l'un des plus
hauts dirigeants du pays qui était visé
le premier vice-président amrullah saleh
un kamikaze se serait fait exploser près
de son convoi alors qu'il se rendait à
son bureau
sortie quasi indemne de l'attaqué il a
rapidement publié une vidéo rassurante
sur facebook un certain nombre de mes
courageux gardes du corps ont été
blessées et ont été évacués vers
l'hôpital des services de renseignement
mon plus jeune fils abdullah qui était
avec moi pendant la taxe va bien mon
fils et moi avons subi quelques brûlures
mineures au visage et ma main a été
légèrement blessé car la puissance de
l'explosion était très forte et a fait
fondre les vitres du véhicule
malheureusement il y a aussi des
dommages matériels
un certain nombre de civils ont été
blessés le lieu où l'explosion s'est
produite
était une rue étroite
cet attentat témoigne aussi de la
violence persistante dans le pays malgré
des négociations qui se poursuivent
entre le gouvernement et les talibans de
nouveaux pourparlers doivent démarrer
bientôt au qatar après avoir été reporté
à plusieurs reprises en cause notamment
des désaccords autour d'un échange de
prisonniers
aujourd'hui presque achevée un contexte
d'instabilité qui met également en
exergue les difficultés d'application de
l'accord entre les taliban et washington
le texte signé à doha en février dernier
prévoit notamment un retrait des soldats
américains en 2021 selon la maison
blanche le président américain devrait
faire une annonce dans ce sens
rapidement et pour en parler nous sommes
avec pierre martinet un ancien agent de
la dgse bonsoir pierre martinet merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france en cette
attaque à kaboul alors que précisément
on nous dit en administration américaine
novik président américain va
prochainement annoncer un retrait
renouveau retraite soldats américains en
afghanistan une réaction de votre part
alors comme vous le disiez en préambule
c'est ça faisait partie de son programme
électoral dont keith héroïque se
retirent d'irak se retire de l'existant
et il va laisser quand même quelques
forces sur place
un embryon de je crois que avec et
prochain retrait il y aura à peu près
5000 américains sur place
ce n'est pas rien mais ce n'est pas ce
qu'on a connu par le passé
la situation a quand même évolué elle et
il ya moins il ya moins de conflits
armés en revanche ça s'est transformé en
zone d'attentât s'est encore encore
encore aujourd'hui mais il y en a eu
plusieurs
depuis de nombreuses années soit
revendiqué par les talibans avant les
accords et soir revendiqué par par
l'état islamique parce que peut pas
oublier que l'état islamique
aujourd'hui est présent en afghanistan
essaye de déstabiliser le pays comme il
l'a fait dans la zone irako syrienne et
comme il le fait en libye
ça veut dire clairement pierre martinet
que selon vous il ya quand même un
progrès
sur place on sait pas exactement comme
ça qu'on doit saisir les choses alors le
conflit armé a changé il n'y a plus le
confia le conflit armé que l'on a connu
par le passé
je vous rappelle qu'il ya quand même de
nombreux militaires français qui ont été
tués je prends à plus de 80 83 ou 84
il ya eu de nombreux militaires
américains de tuer anglais canadiens il
y avait une force internationale qui
était présente
après le après après le 11-septembre et
d'être d'ailleurs aujourd'hui c'est
l'anniversaire de la mort de de
l'assassinât du commandant massoud un
qu'il ya deux jours avant les attentats
du 11 septembre qui a déclenché
l'invasion américaine en afghanistan
s'est s'était voulue par par ben laden
la situation a évolué à changer je dirai
pas quel que que la paix est revenue en
afghanistan loin de là en revanche ce
qui est inquiétant c'est le nombre de
talibans qui est qui et qui a été
libérée qui est encore qui va encore
active rsa peu partie des accords aussi
avec les américains est selon moi la
situation pourrait s'aggraver d'ici
quelques mois quelques années si les
américains retirent totalement leurs
troupes
je pense que ça ça pourrait revenir
comme pas comme en 2001 mais avec de
nombreux attentats et avec de nombreux
nombreuses déstabilise déstabilisation
du plan politique emplacement en tout
cas décision avec les prises de négocier
avec ces talibans c'est ces pourparlers
n'ont d'ailleurs bientôt commencer avec
lui entre les négociateurs oui entre les
négociateurs afghan et les talibans ça
paraît mal mal parti mais je pense que
c'est pas c'est pas très clair lors
leurs négociations ne faut pas oublier
que non plus que le taliban en depuis le
début l'intention de d'avoir un état
islamique sur place et l'afghanistan
c'est le resta islamique donc je pense
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut pas faux
pas le faux pas le l'oublier et malgré
les comment dirais-je les petites
avancées vers une solution à plusieurs
comment dirais-je à plusieurs partis ça
me fait penser un peu ça fait penser un
peu au liban avec le hezbollah donc vous
savez c c'est une partie plus ou moins
politique mais il reste la partie
violente et armé qui a quand même
l'intention d'avoir un état islamique en
afghanistan et
celui qui comprend quelque chose qui
pensent détenir la solution en
afghanistan je lui souhaite bien du
courage parce que c'est pas c'est pas
une solution facile quoi mais que
fallait il faire précisément puisque les
américains voilà ça fait partie de leur
programme on l'a dit veulent se retirer
les guerres sans fin c'est stop pour
donald trump et d'un autre côté on a
lancé des pourparlers qui semble pour
vous vous l échec puisque ces talibans
souhaitant un état islamique en tout cas
sur place que fallait il faire alors
déjà je suis très loin d'être placé
d'être le mieux placé pour donner des
conseils selon moi il faut pas il faut
pas oublier que derrière leur derrière
l'état le taliban comme l'état islamique
ou d'autres où al-qaïda il y à
l'attention de d'avoir un état géré par
la luiss invite donc les talibans sont
une partie très comment dire est très
rigoriste et très extrémiste delà de
cette religion ils ont l'intention pour
l'instant laissons moi je pense qu'il
faut laisser quand même la chance à 7 à
ces négociations à ces accords de paix
enfin ces accords qui sont petits ronds
qui sont passés cette année en revanche
ça n'apporte ça n'empêche pas les les
attentats pour déstabiliser ces accords
alors ce qu'il fallait faire c'est
sûrement pas se retirer totalement de
l'afghanistan parce que ça pourrait
laisser ou ou se retirer mais encore
plus progressivement en revanche il faut
tant que l'état le tas ne sera pas
comment dirais-je plus gangrenés par la
corruption et que ça sera plus passera
pas un état réellement démocratique
je pense que la solution en afghanistan
est loin d'être trouvé quoi merci en
tout cas pierre martinet je rappelle que
vous êtes un ancien agent de la dgse
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons lubrique site le royaume
uni a reconnu vouloir revenir sur
certains engagements pris à la sortie de
l'union européenne
a sion le droit international et à
quelques jours du huitième en des
négociations un accord entre lui et le
royaume-uni est-il encore envisageable
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
m
entre 800 et 1000 tonnes de fuel se sont
déversés dans les eaux turquoises
mauricienne ce qu'il faudrait étendre
l'enquète aux autorités portuaires voir
plus haut et une enquête d'une fois nous
maintenant établir la chaîne de
responsabilités nationales
il faut savoir que la partie arrière du
bateau contient encore environ 50 à 100
tonnes de fioul
donc ça pourrait aussi actuellement se
fracasser et causé un deuxième
déversement de pétrole plus ça arrive
après les communes 19 avons secteur
hôtelier et touristique des impacts de
la catastrophe sur l'environnement marin
mais aussi sur les populations niveau de
la santé devront se faire ressentir
pendant des décennies il faut s'attendre
aujourd'hui à maurice aussi un désastre
sanitaire
il est catastrophe on air a vécu voilà
pourquoi je suis pas si pessimiste que
c'est
[Musique]
c'est déjà une bonne idée d'investir
dans autre chose que des produits
financiers il faut savoir que quand on
achète une pierre précieuse il faut
toujours toujours avoir un certificat
qui est parfait et puis reconnue au
niveau owni commentaire que vous avez
beaucoup de gens qui sont sortis de
leurs investissements je dirais
classiques et sont allés se réfugier sur
du tangible
il ya plusieurs risques il faut il faut
il faut les prendre en compte si on fait
si on n'est pas très bien payé
là il faut savoir que quand vous achetez
une pierre c'est pas pour les dix jours
qui suivent
et c'est un investissement de long terme
le marché des pierres précieuses dont
évidemment s'arrêter un petit peu plus
ou moins de travailler pendant deux mois
mais les grands charmes lumière pour le
diamant retiennent la marchandise en
amont pour maintenir les prix les prix
assez élevé les blanchons les bébés
phoques du groenland naissent sur la
banquise de la mer blanche
tout au long du xxème siècle les bébés
phoques ont été chassés pour leur
fourrure blanche comme neige
depuis que la chasse aux phoques est
interdite en russie il n'y a que les
touristes qui viennent voir ces animaux
à l'état sauvage
mais ces petits seront ils toujours en
sécurité
[Musique]
la crise du courant d'un virus s'aggrave
en amérique latine la situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
présidant un brésilien g1 max hoarau ni
la gravité la pandémie il a été élu
c'est par un dictateur il reste encore
populaire et donc évidemment sa façon de
se comporter par rapport au virus a de
l'impact auprès des brésiliens
aujourd'hui le gouvernement travaille
fortement pour s'approprier les
territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaît nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
le merci nous rejoindre en direct sur rt
france 21h30 heure de paris situation
toujours aussi tendue entre bruxelles et
londres l'union européenne demande une
réunion d'urgence au britannique la
cause la publication par le gouvernement
johnson du projet de loi controversé qui
vise à renier une partie de ses
engagements pris dans le cadre du braque
site et précision de pierre qui savent
yverdon s'affranchir d'une partie de ses
engagements pris dans le cadre du brics
it
voilà l'objectif derrière cette nouvelle
manoeuvre politique de londres alors que
les deux parties sont entrées en début
de semaine dans leur dernier cycle de
négociations
l'impatience des britanniques a coupé
les ponts avec l'ancien allié irrite les
hauts responsables européens très
préoccupé par les annonces du
gouvernement britannique sur ses
intentions de violer l'accord de retrait
cela enfreindrait le droit international
et saperait la confiance pacta sunt
servanda le fondement de relations
futures prospères d'allemagne demande
des explications
la france elle se prépare à tous les
scénarios
cette manoeuvre politique fâche l'europe
toute entière mais pas que au sein même
du parlement britannique boris johnson
est bousculé par des députés qui
dénoncent aussi cette décision cette
législation est contraire au droit
international mais elle en fera
également le droit national
le premier ministre et ses amis une
bande de voyous sont en train de créer
un état voyou un état ou l'état de droit
ne s'applique pas pourquoi le premier
ministre pense-t-il que lui et ses amis
sont au dessus de la loi bien au
contraire monsieur le président ce
projet de loi britannique sur le marché
intérieur vise à protéger des emplois à
préserver la croissance
assurer la fluidité et la sécurité de
notre marché intérieur et la prospérité
dans tout le royaume uni
il devrait être bien accueilli je crois
en écosse en irlande du nord au pays de
galles et dans tout le pays
londres est donc déterminé à mettre en
oeuvre ses projets quitte à accentuer
les tensions avec l'union européenne
une décision qui rapproche encore un peu
plus
les deux parties d'un odile et avant de
débattre de cette question avec nos
invités frédéric viale et florian
philippot on va voir comment est perçu
ce bras de fer
outre-manche nous sommes en direct avec
francesco rizzotto pour notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soir un bon soir à
francesco rizzotto vous êtes chercheur à
l'université de edge il merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
outreman justement comment voit-on ce
bras de fer qui s'installe entre l'union
européenne et londres à chaque étape en
soi et cela dépend de votre position
quant au débat autour du président
les partisans du président selon trompe
plus d'indulgence envers le gouvernement
c'est aussi simple que ça on se dit pas
un petit peu que boris johnson ne jouent
pas le jeu de la loyauté dans cet
épisode tout à fait ceux qui sont contre
le brésil tc la seconde partie de ma
réponse considère cela comme une action
honteuse pour être franc on ne peut pas
signer un accord et le déchirer dix mois
plus tard avec toutes les conséquences
que cela implique
notre parole est essentiel dans l'ombre
moderne si nous ne respectons pas notre
parole alors c'est désastreux
clairement aujourd'hui il n'y a pas une
forme de lassitude après un référendum
qui date quand même il ya plus de 2 34
ans au royaume uni effectivement il ya
de la lassitude
mais la question est la relation future
sa forme avec l'union européenne
aujourd'hui cela n'est pas encore clair
le gouvernement actuel
royaume uni souhaiterait un accord qui
nous donnerait tous les bénéfices de la
concurrence avec l'union européenne sur
les sujets qui nous intéressent sans
rien payer en contrepartie en fait
choisi comme sur un menu c'est vraiment
un grand pari pour le premier ministre
clairement pour boris johnson c'est le
beurre et l'argent du beurre
tout à fait je dois rajouter une
information publique le premier ministre
court de deux grands classiques lorsque
d'abord il risque de se disloquer
je suis le royaume uni les écossais les
irlandais du nord et les gallois
n'apprécie pas du tout ce qui se passe
je pense notamment que l'ecosse les
élections sont proches pourrait décider
de voter pour l'indépendance
le second problème est qu'il a une
majorité dans la chambre des communes
il a à donner des postes à certains de
ses amis dans la chambre des lords mais
la chambre des lords pourrait repousser
un projet de loi qui irait à l'encontre
du droit international donc il faut
étudier la situation au delà des
premières pages vous parlez ranger les
autos de des dangers encourus par le
premier ministre mais à l inverse ce que
ce coup de poker pourrait s'avérer
gagnant pour lui si l'europe
cd il aurait finalement tout gagné et
tout fait gagner pour le royaume uni
je pense que boris hudson est un grand
barrière mais les parieurs ne peuvent
pas toujours remporter la mise
si l'union européenne cède alors l'union
européenne pour
dangers importants comme l'espagne au
16ème siècle elle se retrouverait avec
un état pirate à ses frontières qui
pourrait gâcher la situation au sein du
continent donc je ne pense pas que
l'union européenne va céder les
conditions de concurrence équitables
sont très importantes pour tous les
acteurs c'est un pari et en l'occurrence
le temps et la a donné la plus
importante que la situation va se
résoudre dans les quatre semaines à
venir
il faut donc observer ce qui se passera
dans la chambre des lords
c'est donc effectivement un jeu de poker
que même aux riches johnson il est haute
acculé c'est très clair merci francesco
rizzuto professeur de droit européen à
l'université de edge il au royaume-uni
merci à vous et on l'aura compris donc
huitième ronde de négociations lundi
toujours aucune avancée notamment sur
les dossiers sensibles comme la pêche et
la finance michel barnier négociateur en
chef de l'uss se dit très inquiet quant
aux anglais bien ils prennent leur temps
on l'aura saisi tout en voulant
désormais revenir sur certains
engagements pris à la sortie de l'union
européenne la colère monte au sein des
vingt-sept d'où cette question ce soir
faut-il mettre rapidement les anglais
sur le banc de touche de l'union
européenne pour en parler nous sommes
avec frédéric viale docteur en droit
bonsoir frédéric viale merci d'être avec
nous à ses côtés florian philippot
président du parti des patriotes bonsoir
à vous également florian philippot alors
question un peu voilà pied dans le plein
pour démarrer mais qu'elle mérite d'être
clair est-ce qu'il est temps finalement
d'accélérer le mouvement est ce qu'il ne
faut pas rapidement coupé les ponts avec
les britanniques no deal
et puis tant pis frédéric viale non je
crois que la question ne devrait
véritablement ne se pose pas de cette de
cette manière là en réalité
il y à des gesticulations actuellement
mais pour comprendre ce qui est en train
de se passer il faut bien voir que les
deux c'est à dire aussi bien du côté de
l'union européenne que du côté du
gouvernement britannique les deux sont
des néolibéraux radicaliser qui de toute
façon veulent un accord de libre échange
alors ils sont obligés d'avoir un
discours politique pour vendre à leurs
l'opinion que eh bien ils ont
effectivement du côté britannique fait
la rupture et du côté de l'union
européenne ils ont passé le message
comme quoi il était très difficile de
sortir de l'union européenne puisque
c'est ça que veut passer comme message
devenu rebelle mais en réalité ils sont
dans tous les deux libres échangistes et
donc finalement qu'il y ait pas d'accord
tout de suite ou qu'il y en ait un peu
plus tard ne change fondamentalement pas
au fait qu'il y aura au fond un accord
sur l'essentiel c'est à dire sur le
libre échange qui est le coeur même de
la nature par la nature même de l'union
européenne
donc de ce point de vue là je pense
qu'il ya pas beaucoup à s'inquiéter
enfin elle pas à s'inquiéter on
s'inquiète pas du tout mais il n'y a pas
beaucoup à imaginer que il va y avoir
véritablement la nécessité de forcer les
anglais à faire quoi que ce soit ils
sont dans une logique qui est très
compréhensible finalement florian
philippot est ce qu'on n'est pas un peu
trop aimable avec un os nos chers amis
un britannique après tout ils ont voulu
quitter rapidement l'europe maintenant
il est peut-être le temps de se dire
bye-bye n'ont l'habitude façon les
britanniques défendent leurs intérêts
nationale et il respecte la souveraineté
de leur peuple puisque leur peuple a
voté par référendum
et contrairement à ce qu'on avait vu en
france quand nous on a voté la dernière
fois qu'on a eu le droit de voter par
référendum sur l'europe c'était en 2005
nous on n'a pas eu droit à cette espèce
a été bafouée par les parlementaires
trois ans plus tard que le traité de
lisbonne
donc les et le web se respecter la
volonté de son papa règlement il défend
son intérêt national ça peut entraîner
des négociations un peu ap
surtout que côté l'union européenne
évidemment depuis le début bas tout est
fait pour qu'on mette des bâtons dans
les roues pour essayer de punir les
anglais de leur vote pour essayer de
montrer aux autres peuples pour éviter
un effet domino évidemment pour montrer
que
pas quitter sans douleur c'était valérie
pécresse qui avait dit il faut qu'il
parte dans la douleur il faut que ce
soit douloureux
voilà ça c'est pas une drôle de
conception de la démocratie
moi je ne fais pas de souci pour les
britanniques ils partiront ils sont déjà
aux trois cartes partie le 31 décembre
ils seront totalement partie ils auront
la souveraineté ils pourront décider de
tout un tas de choses que nous
aujourd'hui français on ne peut plus
décider démocratiquement
alors c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui ils sont
sur le libre échange comme comme l'union
européenne mais la grosse différence
c'est que si demain les français aient
voté pour un gouvernement les avait
l'aspiration à au protectionnisme par
exemple eh bien ils pourraient ils
auraient voté pour un gouvernement
protectionnistes puisque nous sommes
dans l'union européenne et ses traités
qui ont pour adn le libre échange on
continuerait quand même avec le
libre-échange
alors que les britanniques ils vont
choisir démocratiquement ils vont
choisir soit le libre échange est
effectivement ce qui est plutôt leurs
traditions effectivement soit ils
pourraient choisir demain le
protectionnisme et eux ils ont le choix
non la pas et c'est vrai ça sur plein de
sujets les politiques la politique
migratoire la politique industrielle la
politique commerciale la politique
environnementale etc
c'est toute la différence entre un peu
plus libre un peuple qui ne l'est pas
alors ils ont le droit effectivement la
france en tout cas et l'union européenne
avec elle le droit d'avoir un partenaire
peut être loyal dans ces négociations
c'est ce que semble dire
gabriel atteint le porte parole du
gouvernement qui affirme aujourd'hui que
paris se prépare à tous les scénarios du
bric si tu écoutes et gabriela talent
nous avons pris connaissance comme vous
l'avez dit de ce texte diffèrent
l'accord de retrait qui a été négocié
est ce que je veux dire au nom du
gouvernement français c'est que la
france attend le respect plein et entier
de l'accord de sortie qui a été signée
que nous sommes prêts à négocier de
bonne foi mais que pour cela il faudrait
trop de me2 et que nous attendrons donc
un interlocuteur à la table des
discussions de bonne foi et qui
évidemment dans ce contexte nous nous
préparons tous les scénarios mais que
notre état d'esprit et de continuer la
discussion avec michel barnier mobilise
in pour cela autour du louvre exit
frédéric viale je m'adresse au docteur
en droit vous aide il ya quand même une
violation du droit international
effectivement la france n'a pas raison
n'at-elle pas raison d'attendre un
partenaire de bonne foi avec des
méthodes mme royal non mais bien entendu
mais la question eric aujourd'hui on est
dans le cadre d'une négociation sortie
avec des échéances qui sont des
échéances politiques qui se posent au
gouvernement britannique
en réalité cette affaire là du bric site
c'est un petit peu le sketch de muriel
robin si vous cherchiez vous souvenez le
jusqu'à ce jour la coiffeuse on coup
pour coup mais on garde toute la
longueur c'est un peu ça à la
négociation du brics y est c'est à dire
que les deux aujourd'hui aussi bien la
commission que le gouvernement
britannique vol du libre échange
simplement ils doivent vendre à leurs
opinions d'une part pour le gouvernement
britannique qu'il a eu raison de sortir
et d'autre part pour le la commission
européenne que elle veut passer le
message aux peuples européens que
l'union européenne on n'aime pas et on
la quitte pas voilà c'est ça le les
confrontations des deux donc en fait on
est dans une à un moment de rodomontades
politique où chacun montre ses muscles
et chacun montre ses muscles pour
essayer de dire c'est moi qui vais
obtenir le meilleur accord mais en
réalité
sur le fond il y a très peu de
différence entre les deux c'est à dire
entre ce que joël gouvernement
britannique aujourd'hui est ce que veut
la commission ce qui se passe c'est que
le bouillon britannique saute sur
l'accord
de pêche et sur l'irlande pour dire à
son opinion publique
oui moi je fais un accord de rupture
mais en réalité en dehors de ça on va
ils vont trouver et je suis à peu près
certain ils vont trouver un accord y
compris en sacrifiant les intérêts par
exemple l'union européenne à sacrifier
l'intérêt des pêcheurs français
j'en suis à peu absolument convaincu
pour trouver finalement un accord au
bord du bush mais c'est à chaque fois
est ce genre de rodomontades je crois
qu'il n'y a rien là d' extrêmement
vraiment d'extrêmement définitif est
florian philippot vous vous partagez
cette analyse frédéric viale on imagine
que ça vous et quand vos vos oreilles
chez les patriots sacrifier l'intérêt
des pêcheurs français
vous pensez que c'est ce qui va se
passer au final à moi j'ai toujours dit
aux pêcheurs français n'en voulait pas
au britannique melanie qui ils ont voté
et les vidéos évidemment les
gouvernements le britannique va défendre
les pêcheurs britannique ça faut pas
s'attendre à autre chose il va pas
défendre les pêcheurs français
non il faut en vouloir au gouvernement
français qui d'abord dans sur l'ensemble
du globe à ce que la france n'allait pas
que en europe c'est aussi le deuxième
espace maritime du monde sur l'ensemble
de nos espaces pensée dans le monde ont
fait très mal respecté notre espace
maritime notre espace de pêche
1 pouvez en parler le comité lui année
ils en savent quelque chose mais est par
ailleurs la france s'est mise tout de
suite dans une situation depuis le début
de ce bras exit dans une situation de
blocage de tension au lieu de négocier
sagement de discuter le sagement avec
avec les britanniques qui avaient voté
en juin 2016 donc évidemment on n'a pas
voulu négocier en fait donc donc à la
fin effectivement ce sont les pêcheurs
français qui lisent le trinquet mais ce
sera la responsabilité du gouvernement
français pas les britanniques peut pas
les accuser là dessus pour le reste moi
je ça me fait rire de voir l'union
européenne faire la leçon ou ses porte
paroles c'est à dire les ministres
français faire la leçon sur le respect
des traités du désaccord puisque
puisqu'on sait très bien qu'en 2011 par
exemple l'union européenne a violé ses
propres traités qu'elle ne viole en
permanence est donc allé violent quand
ça allait quand ça l'arrangé et en
revanche elle réelle demande le respect
absolu des textes quand ça les arrange
aussi ça montre que cette structure la
vie doit absolument disparaître le plus
vite possible parce qu'elle n'a pas de
principes
directeur il faut faire le fch exit le
plus vite possible dans ce cas c'est le
souhait des patriotes vous le savez
voilà moi c'est ce que j'ai à dire là
dessus et encore une fois que les
britanniques face de la realpolitik 1
qu' ils défendent leur intérêt national
dans les négociations qui est un peu un
moment à biaiser oui à faire un petit
coup tordu ça ne choque pas on n'a qu'à
faire la même chose on a peut être un
peu plus malins et moi aussi à défendre
nos intérêts nationaux
plutôt que de faire confiance à les
textes européens défendu par des
technocrates gavé par des lobbys
financiers
frédéric viale le mot de la fin pour
vous les anglais en dehors de l'europe
quel est concrètement le risque pas si
grand selon vous relativisez oui
évidemment c'est à dire que là
maintenant la véritable échéance qui est
celle qui se posent à l'union européenne
est ouvert le britannique
ce n'est pas les 38 jours par donc a
annoncé johnson c'est le 3 novembre le 3
novembre il ya 20 il va y avoir des
élections aux états unis ce sera trompe
ou pas trump 6 et trunks alors
effectivement johnson va se sentir des
ailes pour faire une diplomatie on va
dire assez iconoclaste qui sera en
coquilles ira encore plus loin on va
dire dans le symbole de la rupture mais
sur le chou que ce soit trump ou un
autre on aura de toute façon des
relations avec entre l'union européenne
qui est néo libérale et le gouvernement
britannique et néolibéral on aura des
relations de libre échange
le reste c'est un petit peu on va dire
de la rodomontade c'est un petit peu des
muscles qu'on montre comme ça dans des
négociations rien de plus merci en tout
cas tous les deux frédéric viale florian
philippot d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
débat sur le break site alors qu'on
attend donc lundi le huitième à la 8ème
séance de négociations
l'europe au secours de la grèce de
violents incendies ont ravagé le camp
migan de moya situé sur l'île grecque de
lesbos une catastrophe humanitaire qui
laissent des milliers de personnes dans
le besoin d'un abri d'urgence cyrielle
bruit des cendres de la fumée et des
ruines c'est tout ce qu'il reste du plus
grand camp de réfugiés de grèce ce
mercredi un incendie ravageur s'est
déclaré dans la nuit emportant tout sur
son passage
des centaines de migrants ont dû finir
leur nuit à même le sol
une situation dramatique qui touche le
pays tout entier
j'exprime ma tristesse concernant les
événements d'hier à moria je reconnais
les circonstances difficiles
toutefois rien ne peut servir d'excusé
une réaction violente aux contrôles
sanitaires et surtout à des troubles de
cette ampleur
la situation à moriat ne peut pas
continuer car elle constitue à la fois
une question de santé publique
d'humanité et de sécurité nationale afin
que halak avait fuité sociale selon
plusieurs ong
le camp de moria était devenu une
véritable honte pour l'europe entière
et pour cause surnommé la jungle ce camp
d'une capacité de 2700 places abriter
plus de douze mille migrants
après la découverte d'un cas de kovy 19
dans ces structures
le camp était en confinement total et ce
jusqu'au 21 septembre prochain une
catastrophe humanitaire qui relance donc
le débat sur l'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile en europe face aux terribles
incendies à moria nous pensons aux
personnes en détresse et aux habitants
de lesbos avec ses partenaires la france
est prête à apporter le soutien
nécessaire
comme nous l'avons indiqué au
gouvernement grec la grèce a désormais
besoin de notre soutien et solidarité
nous avons besoin de manière urgente
dans programme d'accueil commun de la
part du plus grand nombre possible
d'états de l'union européenne et enfin
d'une politique migratoire et d'asile
commune
une situation qui soulève l'indignation
également en allemagne à berlin un
rassemblement s'est tenu ce mercredi en
soutien aux réfugiés du camp grec
les manifestants demandent l'évacuation
de maria et la réouverture des
frontières afin d'accueillir ces
migrants reste à savoir si les membres
de l'union européenne seront trouver un
terrain d'entente sur ce sujet épineux
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve dans
quelques minutes à 22 heures précisément
pour un point complet sur l'actualité de
la journée
[Musique]
rodolphe gombergh vous avez découvert
que l'imagerie médicale qui était le
coeur de votre métier avait une
dimension artistique me suis aperçu que
c'était l'art qui faisait avancer la
science et la science qui faisait
avancer là l'image est belle mais mais
en général le mal qu'elle révèle il est
terrifiant au moment du coc vite quand
j'ai attrapé bois même la maladie je me
suis dit mais pourquoi j'utilise pas ma
technique de droite et de virton life a
pour mon thorax propres et pour le virus
j'ai pu suivre son évolution comme henry
ça s'aggravait ou au contraire comment
ça s'est battu mais quand on a découvert
le qu il dansait on sait comment ils et
comment
voilà quelle couleur il est qu'on a
découvert le mal les mèches du mal ici
on écrire ce qu'ils ne sont pas d'accord
[Musique]